mana I know you're a Taylor Swift fan I
mean I might have written a rhetorical
analysis on her 1989 album
Wow we have recently been talking to
some celebrities who are big bachelor
nation fans and there are little things
to say about you we pulled the bites
together let's take a look
I do think Hannah can stay home now
now they're just using these poor women
it's like now it's you know it's the
same yeah at their sake
she's showing up a proposal and she's
throwing a whole spanner in the wheel
yeah
who Jennifer Aniston and Charlize Theron
do you think it's shady no look I
understand I just keep coming up with
some people do think that you are gonna
show up and Peter and you might be
engaged right now wild y'all do you keep
watching is that way if we have to
always say do you show up on this season
again I do not know yes but it's okay if
you can't tell us Peter also told us
that he might have gone down a totally
different road if you had asked him out
take a look at what Peter had to say I
would have said yes and I probably would
have been eventually would you in Hannah
be together right now I mean you never
know the world may never know now you
know it's it is what it is it's hard to
watch that and be like what could I have
done what should I have a dime you still
have any feelings for Peter right now
I'm always going to care for him deeply
he asked you to join his season did you
consider it you know I wanted to do
something for myself and move forward
and it was hard there's a possibility
you could be the Bachelorette again so
would you do that I don't know right now
I'm just like trying to seize the
opportunities that I have and it doesn't
have to be as the Bachelorette so you
are so busy now with Dancing with the
Stars with this unbelievable tour Radio
City Music Hall
it's my mom's dream come true it's going
to be incredible you're gonna kill it
though you won Dancing with the Stars
[Music]